[Music]
this morning on president trump's last
full day in the white house we'll take a
look back at four years of leadership
that as you know left america deeply
divided so we asked our chief washington
correspondent major garrett to open his
reporter's notebook there's a lot of
good stuff in there to show us
what it was like to cover a presidency
unlike any other
i will never ever let you down
to meet donald trump the first time
major
fantastic is to meet him forever
then as a long-shot candidate mr trump
recognized me
in a room full of reporters what do you
mean fairly fairly is an instinct
if you don't like mr trump argued with
me over who won the first gop debate
excuse me did i win that's for you to
decide if you don't say yes then you're
not
a supporter all right goodbye that was
my first inkling candidate trump ever
soon to be president trump was willing
to put the bullying
in bully polly i think you're very
unprofessional president trump loved and
hated the news media he craved our
screeching attention
mr president mr president
and he used it as a foil to whip up
support and to fuel animosity he hoped
would
intimidate us when you report fake news
you are the enemy of the people that
never worked
what did work was the constant
generation of drama
even the kind that shocked and soured
the country
to cover mr trump is to be astonished by
his energy
his combativeness and his ability to
divide
inspire market and deceive all at once
the trump effect has reshaped the
supreme court the tax code the middle
east
trade relations and america's image as
an immigrant's
welcoming home but overall the trump
presidency was about one man
relentlessly at the center of his own
vortex
demanding loyalty barking orders
pardoning friends
demonizing enemies real and imagined
they hate our country mr trump never let
anything go
fighting in all directions even about
the weather would have affected a lot of
other states
few encounters existed without his stage
management
i guarantee i'm not paying for this mic
even to cbs cameraman tony furlon get
back a little tony would you please
that happened on the west front of the
capitol during a peaceful rally opposing
the iran nuclear deal
more than four years later fanatics
inspired by the president
stormed that very ground
[Applause]
[Music]
in the first hour of his presidency from
that same location mr trump introduced
the country to
american carnage foreign nations gutting
our industrial base
this american carnage stops
right here and stops
right now usa but a different kind of
american carnage visited the capitol
january 6th
and it came not from abroad but from
within
[Applause]
that hideous event that crime against
america
will forever be the first sentence of mr
trump's presidential legacy
wow major garrett joins us now to follow
up on that story major i remember
every single one of those stories and
i'm curious about how you're feeling
today because you go from major
fantastic as he's singing you have to
uh i don't know i'm not going to say
you're on the dead to me list but i'm
going to say you're not going to be
invited to lunch anytime soon
so as you're here on this last day the
last full day how are you going to
remember how do you think he should be
remembered
look it's a complicated story but as i
said in that piece you cannot separate
no one will ever be able to separate
whatever the trump
legacy is from that january 6th event it
is going to be and must be
the first sentence the first time an
american president told a series of lies
over weeks and weeks
and fomented an attack by the executive
branch on the legislative branch
that has never before happened we hope
it never happens again
and it will never be anything other than
the first sentence of the
trump presidential legacy as i mentioned
in that piece other things have been
accomplished
but when you get the constitution wrong
and you put your vice president your
loyal vice president
in real jeopardy everything else you've
done has been tarnished
and now we're moving into joe biden two
very different men
different philosophies on just about
everything how do you think that's going
to change your coverage
well look this new president president
biden will probably be like many of the
presidents before president trump that i
covered
slightly opaque one of the parts of the
trump beat that never existed was
i wonder what the president's thinking
for joe biden we may wonder at
times but with trump we never did all
right major garrett thank you i'll see
you in washington we're coming there
later today we'll see you